there's this crazy funding boom
going into
creating meatless meat and alternative
proteins
because we really need to change the way
we eat and one of the hardest types of
proteins to find and one of the kind of
last
areas that hasn't been getting as much
funding but has recently having a lot of
investors flocking to it is the world of
alternative shellfish and seafood
new wave foods is an extraordinary
company mission based
with a huge business opportunity so the
co-founders saw
that there were tremendous issues in the
supply chain
for seafood particularly for shrimp
ninety percent of what we consume being
imported in only half of that from
shrimp farms
so there was tremendous ecological
damage that was happening through these
farms
and it's the number one seafood
so americans consume a billion and a
half pounds every year so it was a big
business opportunity a big ecological
opportunity and that's what really
formed the the company at its inception
it is extremely hard to recreate a
shrimp without shrimp that still has the
same snap that's expected from a shrimp
and the same
you know fresh out of the ocean to taste
but there are several startups that have
been really trying to perfect it and
spending years in research and
development and food engineering to try
to make it happen and we were really
lucky to get a chance to taste some that
has been
getting worked out for a really long
time as you can get commercialized and
sold in cafeterias and restaurants and
even maybe grocery stores soon
so uh we got the new wave shrimp here
and those go into this uh rice flour
so they get a light dusting of rice
flour they go into this special tempura
batter that is also is gluten free
made with bean potato and rice starches
and then it goes into
360 degree oil
and it fries really nice
uh very delicious and then i've got
japanese brewed organic soy ginger juice
and mirin
is the little dip
[Music]
and some
wakame salad
what we're offering is a one-for-one
swap and it's used exactly as shrimp is
used in any recipe
we particularly recommend hot recipes so
entrees and appetizers
and it's delicious when i met the
founders they had a wonderful idea
and they had a good
they had a very good product but there
was definitely
areas for opportunity for improvement
so we stepped back and that's when about
three years ago we went to the culinary
institute of america and we started
working with mass certified master chef
brad barnes
and what we did was we we pulled
together a really extraordinary team to
work on it so we we had people from
academia we had leading food r d folks
we had some of the flavor houses from
around the world so we really kind of
punched over our weight and collected an
extraordinary group of professionals who
worked on this to really create the
texture
and the taste of ocean shrimp and it was
extremely difficult to do
but with that collection of people we
were able to
unlike you know beyond an impossible
which um are pretty entrenched and
there's a lot of you know fake chicken
companies out there right now um
the alternative seafood world still is
kind of like a last frontier um it's
been
taking far longer in development just
because it is so much harder to create
and
meet what we expect so this is a seafood
in that there is seaweed seaweed is one
of the core ingredients
and then for protein we use mung bean
which works very well and then also is
more adapted or i should say more
accepted
versus soy which a lot of plant-based
proteins use so we have none of the top
eight allergens
uh and that's
obviously no shellfish but also none of
the top eight so that's one of the you
know one of the things that we have that
really works well in terms of acceptance
and then
i really can't talk as much to the rest
in that we have so much intellectual
property we currently have national
distribution
so yes so we are partnering with dot
foods and then meanwhile we're sampling
a lot and really in those initial stages
with a lot of the national
chains
the reception has been fantastic it's
been fantastic
i've tried a lot of these fake seafood
products and honestly
many of them really don't hit the mark
shrimp especially giving you that the
third
most eaten protein in all of america is
such a big volume of that and
you know is used in so many ubiquitous
and different types of dishes that it's
been really a holy grail for a lot of
startups but new wave is a leader that
has one of the best chances of really
getting it to more of mainstream and
commercial distribution